[Applause]
thank you very much great to be back
haven't been for ages great to see
familiar faces and also don't forget to
thank you organizers they're doing lots
of work which is a often not seen I'm
just going to talk very quickly about a
little bit of code I wrote which may or
may not be useful to other people for
those who don't know me I used to be
around I moved out of London to Cornwall
that's the end of my village
you have to careful not to fall off into
the sea I run algorithmic art which meet
in London and Coral I've started a dead
sounds choral group in Cornwall which is
growing slowly not many people there and
Curtin a joke Cornell is for kids and
that's quite fun so and the kind of the
itch I wanted to scratch was I want I
use Python obviously I used notebooks
which are lovely they weren't around
when I started sound quite old and it's
great to visualize things in a notebook
but I wanted to visualize things that
are related like graphs sort of entities
that have relationships and the
traditional libraries like MATLAB didn't
seem to have any any answer I wanted
these graphs to be interactive so that I
could zoom in or move things around and
I couldn't find anything there's things
like d3 but it didn't immediately work
in the notebook so it said you couldn't
find anything something called Network
hex popped up on my Google searches and
it does you know work with graph data
and it does plot charts including in a
notebook but they're static and they're
no particularly pretty and you can see
that if I have lots of data it's going
to be overwhelming and saturated so you
didn't really understand what's really
going on and so I thought ok maybe I'll
try writing something myself what I
wanted to do was make it simple so easy
things simple other stuff optional
this is Network X again showing a graph
output up there and there's lots more
code than that's shown is shown on the
screen didn't want to do that I wanted
to just have a data frame like that
things related to the things you know
left-hand column right in column maybe a
way to show the strength of the
connection and I just wanted something
that just plot that data just just draw
lines between those entities and so
wrote some think I'm I I'm not a
professional programmer but it's
actually quite easy and I think there's
only about twenty thirty lines of code
when I say easy I wanted it to be as
easy as importing a module and then
calling a function passing it the days
frame and for it to just just just plot
the damn thing sorcerer language and it
is diseases that there's there's there's
a notebook showing import little
instruction there to create a date frame
I'm printing the data frame so you can
see how easy it is
let me show you it in action this is in
include lab so it works in Google as
well not just a normal you know come
your locally installed it you can do a
pip install and it works in curl up as
well if you're if you're using that
import the library and plot it there you
go and you can grab these things and
move them around if I can get my pointer
to work we I've got a slightly more
interesting example here where I'm
looking at a corpus of text recipes
artificially constructed and I'm just
building a pandas dataframe showing the
co-occurrence of words and you can you
can see more easily which words are
connected if I double click on something
hopefully I'll move the center so what I
really wanted to say is this is there it
was quite easy to do her notebook is
sort of a web page you run Python Python
itself can construct HTML and you can
render HTML including JavaScript in an
output cell so once you understand that
it's not too difficult there are a few
options you know it wasn't us
there is a simple path but you can do
things like you know change the length
of the other links and increase the size
of nodes and so on if your data's sparse
what you've got lots of it so I just
want you to make you aware of that I'm
not aware of any other tools that work
as easily as that in the notebook if you
find it useful if you don't find it
useful let me know and maybe we can
improve it thank you very much
[Applause]